it it looks like we're seeing a bunch of
these stories about
trumpian type uh uh you're laughing
because you're looking at the story we
got ready to go uh-huh yeah yeah
we'll get to it we'll get to it no but
but um so we're gonna talk about laura
loomer for sure
yeah but it looks like we're seeing this
phenomenon on the right
same as we see on the left with a new
kind of populist insurgent
base coming in and pushing out the
establishment politicians
the media doesn't go after it the same
way they go after the squad the squad is
magic
you know 8.3 million followers for aoc
she's the she's the star
but we've got a bunch of uh
conservatives that have been stepping up
to the plate
you know saying something's gonna be
done i'm gonna do it. and
specifically this is a segue into laura
loomer as kind of
the democrats reckoning you know not
necessarily just the democrats but the
the establishment elites
the the the tech technocrats
they tried shutting laura loomer down
and now she's won her primary
she's in a d plus nine district so i'm
wondering if she can actually win
i'm not just doing this you know segment
to be like i mean first of all i think
it's amazing she won her primary i
agreed yeah and and she is i think she's
probably the most driven person i've
seen
i'm not even i'm not even kidding you
can criticize all of her stunts
after being banned from every single
platform she just does not stop
and now she's you know the primary she's
the republican nominee for this district
we'll see if she will see if she wins
but the bigger issue at play
involving her is this story right here
twitter maintains ban on candidate laura
loomer
they say politico says loomer is a
far-right activist whose confrontations
with journalists and political figures
helped her amass an online following
they say quote the account owner you
referenced was permanently suspended for
repeated violations of the twitter rules
we do not plan to reverse that
enforcement action the company said in a
statement
now they're going to go on and talk
about why she was banned but i don't
necessarily trust them
politico's big picture says social media
companies have at times given political
figures more
leeway when their speech violates rules
so the public can hear directly from
their representatives
but it seems that won't be enough to get
loomer tweeting again
do you know what was the like the final
nail in the coffin for her on twitter
i think it was was it the uber thing no
no no it was the ellen omar
oh was it yeah yeah about uh wanting to
see like another 911 or something like
that
no she's she's she said that uh ilhan
omar supports sharia law oh right and
that under sharia
you know these different groups are
marginalized and oppressed and that was
it
and i said you mean you mean to tell me
out of everything she's done it was the
criticizing a politician that
got her the acts on this platform i mean
that's what all the
that's what all the politicians are
doing to each other all the time and now
she's actually a politician
uh you know and they won't restore her
that's that's the precedent
this is this is gonna put the squeeze on
them um it's gonna make them
as blatant put their hypocrisy out there
as blatantly as possible
but if there's one thing that we've
learned so far there's no shame
yeah and and they always double down
yep there's no backtracking there's no
compromising there's no
you know my bad on that one no
they they have to double down so uh
it'll be interesting to see how this
plays out but i just want to say one
thing about laura loomer i met laura
loomer
back a long time ago years ago when she
just had
literally a couple thousand followers
and she was a project veritas
and uh it was clear to me then that she
had an
unstoppable will to succeed there is
absolutely
no question about that she told me that
she was getting anxious being at the
desk and wanted to get out there and do
stuff
and well guess what man she got out
there she did stuff she got banned she
did more she's punk rock
she she like co-opted the system you
know one
quick side note i went to evergreen
state college
to speak at a class there and i thought
that this was going to be an excellent
like news event for me
so i go all the way out to washington i
speak at evergreen state college right
after the brett weinstein wow
all that stuff right nobody knows you
want to know why well not maybe this
isn't the only reason but you want to
know what happened the day
that i'm at i'm at evergreen jack murphy
democrat to deplorables at evergreen
state college
here to like you know be a part of the
whole conversation the weinstein thing
the whole thing
that very day laura loomer chains
herself to the front of
twitter and she hijacked all of twitter
trending number one so like she knows
and she's driven and you know i would
not doubt her ability to see this thing
all the way through
and once if she gets in i mean who knows
who knows so kudos to laura on that
win congratulations laura i mean it yeah
i don't
i don't follow her policy-wise yeah i
mean she's absolutely
been she's had bombastic things on
social media and she's been criticized
for it but
to the people who underestimated her boy
are they going to get a reckoning now
uh-huh
i think she could very well could win i
i'm pretty sure she's betting on it when
when she announced she was running and i
saw this i was like she's in a d plus
nine district yeah
is that i'm like what's the strategy
behind that well it's trump's mar-a-lago
district right
and i think when you have a will of pure
fire like she does no i mean it's funny
because for all the things she's been
made fun of all the stunts she's done
it's all
worked yep indeed and so it's funny when
when people laugh
and i'm like you realize it's part of
the game yeah when she was when she
chained herself to the door of twitter
and everyone on twitter
is laughing it's like they banned her
and then she dominated the platform
yeah they you underestimate your enemy
at your own peril well it's an
interesting uh
sort of thing to look at on a on a
bigger level which is
if you want to be either an activist a
journalist a media person
and you're coming into it with no
established professional network you
don't have corporate backing you're not
just
oh i got hired at new york times and i
got a blue check with 50 followers
you have to earn it yep you have to earn
it
and one of the ways people ask me how do
you grow on twitter i'm like dude
and i read these guys like tweet every
day and add value i'm like nah that's
not gonna do it
you have to literally become the news
you have to like make
the news happen or become something
we're talking about or become an event
and laura went out there and she she
earned all this
all this attention through her work so
whether or not you agree with her
policies or whatnot it is sort of a good
example of new media
like how to build how to build that
capital think about the amount of
um i just i don't know what you'd call
it strategy uh
whatever to take over the news cycle
yeah more than once
i know yeah repeatedly and so when i see
these journalists laughing and making
fun of her i'm like you realize that's
the point
she she's she just made you all give her
all of your attention
and that's a lot of what got trump trump
uh elected was that the media couldn't
shut up about him
and now sure enough laura loomer is
winning the primary well one of the key
fundamental
elements of persuasion is attention
attention is
influence right yep so she's getting
that attention and she is earning her
influence
what she does with it we'll see but it
is
it is a good example of how to build
capital and power within an environment
which is already saturated
yep right there's already a million
players everybody has a phone and a
twitter account except
except for laura and uh and and and yet
you know she made her way all the way up
from from zero
to this through sheer force of will in
only a matter of a couple of years yeah
630 000 followers on parlor though
so once you know given access to a new
platform with followers
but the reason i did want to bring up
laura is not you know to necessarily get
into
the the controversy over you know her
character
no it was specifically how she should
she should absolutely be reinstated
100 this is this is actually this war
this is this is very very worrying that
we come to a point now
you could be 16 years old and get banned
from twitter because you're a dumb kid
now you're in your 30s and you're cut
out from political life because the
social media platforms where people use
for commerce for
communications have banned you from past
discretions
that to me is scary yeah shouldn't
shouldn't she at least be allowed to
have a campaign account
that's run by staff that tweets policy
ideas 100
i think so for sure yeah and now we're
seeing the future that's being carved
out by these lunatics
and i think jack dorsey you know i think
he's a figurehead i don't think he has
any real power
yeah he's he whispers all the sweet
nothings in the world about
decentralized social media and paths or
redemption that never come to fruition
instead it's a publicly traded company
that is desperate for a clean image
and will nuke anybody who they think
threatens their advertising and their
dollars or their stock value
they don't care about politics they
don't care about civic duty they don't
care about the presidency our government
keeping our country safe they said it to
me they're a global company
they you know i get emails and it's like
your tweet was reported but found we
found no violation of german law
you ever get one of those emails not
from a different country no i get it i
get it from
from america definitely but not about
german german law
yeah i've received emails that says your
account was reported but we found no
violations of german law it means people
in germany are reporting it
i have before you know um we've seen a
lot of people
get the notice that notices from i think
pakistan
saying you've found to be in violation
of pakistani law
and i've seen a lot of conservatives get
mad about that why is twitter ascending
me that i've violated pakistani ilama
pakistani and i actually think it's a
good thing they're doing this
because now you know if you go to that
country
they're going to arrest you right
because you blasphemed you know the
prophet or something
right terrifying that
part all of it actually we're addicted
to social media
i'm glad to see parlor getting the
attention that it's getting and becoming
more
prominent did you hear about my fiasco
with parlor yes i did
yeah i'm not a fan not a fan uh they
purged your account where they deleted
everything yeah i signed up within two
days i had like 1400 followers with zero
i followed zero
i said my first few what are you calling
parlays were asking them about their
terms of service
they started deleting my questions about
terms of service in
selectively yeah and then they banned my
account and then i actually got the ceo
on the line on the phone because i
raised the stink on twitter and it was a
hot topic
so it got tweeted all up the chain and
uh the ceo at parlor and i had a
conversation where he promised me that
the terms of service were just
boilerplate and just lawyer stuff and it
was all the lawyer's fault
yeah but uh you know i gave parlor a
shot it's just it
they banned me within five seconds i
think
i think what we need first and foremost
uh section 230 reform yeah i talked
about it quite a bit the the
companies use this there's this law
called section 230 most of you are
probably familiar but for those that
aren't
it shields them from personal you know
their company's liability if
if if i go on twitter and i defame libel
slander jack
jack can't sue twitter as to sue me
section 230 guards them but it also
gives them
specific exemptions for what they can
remove without being considered
a publisher for you know for the purpose
of lawsuits
i believe it should be specifically
illegal speech like threats
yeah you know incitement violence
explaining how to commit crimes things
like that they should be able to remove
that
and other certain issues now we had uh
bill ottman from the ceo of mines on the
show on monday and he made a good point
what about a christian blog that is now
forced to host you know
pornography because it's legal so you've
you know they should have a right to
remove stuff but it becomes particularly
challenging
i think that's an important path forward
but in terms of censorship
we need to find a way to guarantee that
people can't be banned period
and so i think there's something called
the fetaverse i'm not sure if you've
ever heard it's probably pretty
technical
it's here's how it would work you
wouldn't create a twitter account
you'd create your own website and then
people would subscribe
kind of like an rss feed or whatever
yeah so when you post
you know i'll do air quotes a tweet a
simple post what's really happening is
you're just posting to your own website
yeah but other people auto pull it to
their feed so they have a news feed
on their own websites so basically no
one can ban you it's your site
right people subscribe kind of like
email but i think
twitch is something similar to that i
gave that a
shot as well but again you know there's
this critical mass with the networks
that's so important which is why twitter
is what it is you know i think about
what it would be like to have
twitter taken away from me uh you know
it's
it's it's concerning you know and not
necessarily just for like
business side but just like just it's
part of my life
you know right and that's where
virtually almost 100
now of my friends social life
professional life
clients customers network everything
in my life that i talk to every day came
through my experience on twitter
and we've been dming to even set up the
show yeah you know we go on twitter i'm
like yo
jake yeah yeah so i can see why somebody
like laura would
and anybody who gets banned from it
would feel you know a lot of negative
feelings about that
and wouldn't it this would be literary
right like this would be
this would be a literary story if laura
loomer gets banned
from twitter tries to get back on gets
rejected
decides i'm going to do something about
this goes down to florida
gets elected to congress goes to
congress gets on the right committees
makes a stake and somehow pushes reform
for social media through our legislature
that would be
freaking amazing i kind of think that
that will happen
yeah because it's a great character arc
i
i i just gotta say considering what
she's been able to pull off i would not
be surprised if
she wins she gets in yeah she slams her
face on the table and says this is
unacceptable
i am a member of congress how how am i
how do i not have access to my
constituents through digital media
and i wouldn't be surprised if she wins
it i think that the overall level of the
understanding um demonstrated of
technology by
congress at the last round of hearings
has actually increased right it seems as
though
they're starting to actually understand
what the real issues are
yeah um i follow a guy matt stoller
wonderful guy
great book goliath people should read
about it you were talking about
antitrust earlier he's a big anti-trust
guy
and he was talking about and just
remarking openly how
the the caliber of the questions the
understanding demonstrated by the
congress about these issues has actually
grown quite a bit because the first
round
of uh hearings that they did a year or
two ago you know i mean there was just
senators up there just being like so now
tell me how do you send a tweet
yeah you know and and now that now they
really are digging into the serious
issues so
there's progress there who was it who
like asked i can't remember someone
asked one of the tech ceos
he has sundar pachai about an iphone was
that ted cruz or something
no ted's actually had some pretty good
intel i've seen him
cite project veritas research and stuff
up there in the hearing so
he's on the ball but there are some
other people that certainly are not uh
but laura would certainly bring
a different flavor and a new energy to
these investigations and
you know there's something's going to
come of that that that's an amazing
you can write that you can write no one
would believe it i'm not a fan
of i guess negative
and aggressive rhetoric i don't like
insulting people or being mean so i
think there are things that i would you
know
be very critical of of laura loomer over
yes but i think
having a staunch defender of free speech
with that much energy yeah i think
whether you agree with her or not that
kind of energy in politics
is desperately needed i'm not saying her
personal politics that i don't i haven't
gone over her stance on many issues
but it feels like a lot of a lot of
congress a lot of the senate is just do
nothing
you know do nothing politicians who want
the keys to the castle
because they'll get a fat paycheck they
can i think politics attracts
low t like low skill low intellect
people who want an easy path towards
some kind of
name in the history books so they're
like i don't know how to do anything
i'll just tell people they want to hear
so that they elect me and then i get to
be
you know put on the little little chart
of people who have been here right
well now that's joe biden for sure
definitely but that is not donald trump
so exactly and it's not laura loomer
she's there to to bring a reckoning to
the people who for real i mean
vengeance yes i mean yeah
yeah it's it's you you play dirty games
you you get
you know what you deserve well i don't
want to say it too aggressively but an
equal
equal and opposite reaction yeah you you
ban people you shut them out
eventually someone's gonna bite back and
they're gonna come back and now you're
gonna say if
only they let laura loomer keep her
twitter account she wouldn't be in
congress
but this is what this is what happens
when you underestimate your your
opponents
yeah and someone with a will like her
she's going to be in congress and she's
going to be 10 times the thorn in their
side than she would have been on twitter
but they couldn't help themselves no
it's the stupid games they play
they don't they instead of saying i
don't like what you have to say
mute they say i don't like what you have
to say i'm going to try and destroy you
yeah you know what is troubling now that
i think about it is
this is presenting a situation in which
now we're going to have some precedent
if twitter continues to officially ban
if she gets elected yeah and twitter
continues to officially ban
like a sitting elected congressman or
congresswoman
then that is not that much farther from
then just like
banning a presidential candidate exactly
they've already said that you know
donald trump can tweet things
and if they break the rules we'll flag
them right that means today
someone who's 25 who could possibly be a
future president
could get banned for saying the same
thing as our current president
that makes no sense right our current
president is speaking
if you repeat him you'll get banned and
then you can't when you become president
you have no access
dude if he uh the the the moment
his term is up whether it's at the end
of this year four years from now
like literally the moment that the clock
goes like
his twitter account's gone don't you
think yeah
i don't think it'll be a hammer drop
snap because they love making money off
them
right i think trump saved twitter yeah i
do politics saved a lot of media
companies this
trump and politics and this 2016 stuff
yeah absolutely
yeah when before trump
twitter was actually hard to use
confusing
and it was losing users because you know
it used to be about following
celebrities and celebrity gossip
then trump started using it and it just
exploded because now
his supporters were signing up his you
know haters were signing up
and i think the reason they won't ban
him is because he's the linchpin now
they pull that pin out the whole
platform unravels becomes boring yeah
and there's no conversation anymore that
is possible so i
but you're but you're right in the sense
that if he's out of office he doesn't
provide that service anymore
he's no longer a strong voice
he'll he'll still have his voice he'll
still have millions and millions of
followers he'll still be a former
president
and he'll chime in periodically but it
won't have the immediate impact as he's
no longer in office
yeah and i know they're all worried
about it yeah there there was a report
from digiday saying that media companies
are panicking about what
over what happens if trump loses yeah
their revenue is going to get cut in
half
i love it when he says that just
blatantly straight out to them you guys
love me you need me i'm making you money
yep that's awesome you know what man i
say this every time it happens
when bloomberg started dumping money on
youtube yeah i was like
i'll make it rain bloomberg those
bloomberg bucks follow fl
fall all over youtube with those youtube
that youtube revenue yeah i will
absolutely take his money to make fun of
him
because i'm not making videos for him
but you know what he does what what
biden does with
what they do is they like putting ads on
videos that challenge them so they can
push back
and it's i don't think it's going to
work no one's going to trust you trust
your canned advertisement over
me chilling and having a long you know
giving you a long rant about my ideas
yeah but donald trump just did i think
it was like one of the biggest ad buys
ever
a seven figure like seven figures in a
single month just just
blanketed this month and the democrats
didn't do anything
and you know joe biden's been raising
money why won't they spend it
why won't they spend it they're going to
save it they don't even know how to
spend it
they don't know how to do social media
like trump knows how to do it and
and even so trump could be doing it even
better i mean there's so much more he
might be doing i think but
he he is he's setting the pace and he
is the one out front and whether they
say it or not he's probably
in the lead at the moment anyway so
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast we do the show
live monday through friday at 8 p.m if
you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you